one time we heard a call by Michael who
was standing on the stair steps of this
building come on here y'all I want you
to see something I wanted to see
something right and he's tall stone and
Robert walking together down the street
we're all looked and say yeah you're
right right he said let's ask yeah
michael says to those guys have you
acted before they said no come on
Michael said come on here you got two
parts mi mi I'm not lying
that's we did is that is that how you
cast stone in Robert yes I was I had
Gloria had Gloria preceded us coming to
Chicago I was I was fighting with with a
IP saying we gotta be in Chicago we
gotta shoot this film and finish it
before the hawk hits right there will be
no I in the winter and so Gloria
proceeded Stephen and me coming and she
found all of these great kids she found
Jackie Taylor she found Robert Townsend
and I had found everybody except these
two thugs right and and the all the
agents were sending were these clean
scrub young black guys you know
commercial type guys and I said no no I
need the grit you know when I saw these
two guys walking down down the street
I said that's been exactly what I'm
looking and Jackie knows yeah well is
what's interesting is that when you cast
Ricky in Norman in Cabrini Ricky lived
upstairs
Ricky live downstairs for me and I lived
upstairs and he still works for me today
at my theater
why are you still an actor yeah but he
called me and he said you know this this
this dude I'm talking about he want me
and Norman in a movie you know it's
called Cooley high and huh is he for
real
I say yeah Ricky he's he's for real and
he said should I do it I say hell yeah
me yeah yeah yeah you should do it he
said what I tell you what we don't do it
but if it don't work out we don't steal
some god
[Applause]